hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to
talk about some things that you can do
if you miss a vein whenever you're
starting an iv
missing a vein whenever you're starting
an iv is something that you just don't
want to do whether you're a new nurse or
a seasoned nurse but it's something that
unfortunately
does happen even for the most seasoned
nurse there there will be times where
they miss
veins so you know as a nurse you don't
want to miss that vein because
usually whenever you're having to start
an iv on a patient it's for a reason
you've got to give a medication that
needs to really be given right then
and there or if you're the patient you
don't want to have to be stuck
with a needle over and over so first
whenever you do
miss a vein you want to make sure that
you have a good reaction to it
because you don't want to have one of
the two extremes like one extreme would
be
that you blame the patient for why you
miss the iv
like telling the patient oh man you have
horrible veins
and i can't get i don't know how anyone
really gets an iv on you
that could really offend the patient and
make them feel bad about themselves
or um you are just overly apologetic
and you're like i'm just so sorry i'm so
sorry i'm just really not good at this
i'm new here and just keep apologizing
instead you want to be tactful with how
you respond
for instance you can say okay this
didn't work over here so is it okay if i
look in this other arm
and one thing i do before i actually
start an iv on a patient
is that number one i ask them if it's
okay if i start an iv on them and
explain what an iv is if they're not
familiar with it
and then i ask them what vein i can use
on their arm because patients know their
body so much better than we do
and a lot of times patients will tell me
hey they always get an iv
over here in this arm and this is where
i prefer and nine times out of ten i'll
go there there's an awesome vein
and i'm able to stick it first try and
i'm glad i listened to the patient
and another thing to keep in mind if you
do miss is to always
ask the patient's permission if you can
attempt to stick them again
because some patients i have found they
will actually tell you no
i don't want any more attempts i'm not
having an iv
and then also you want to look at your
hospital's protocols
because many times these protocols will
dictate how much
an individual nurse can attempt to stick
a patient for an iv
and sometimes it's limited to two so you
always want to be familiar with that and
the next thing
is that you have to maintain confidence
especially whenever you miss
after that first attempt so you know
whenever you do miss after that first
attempt your confidence is already like
deflating and you're thinking yourself
oh no
i hope i really get this especially if
you have a patient
who is really putting the squeeze on you
and they're saying okay you're not
trying anymore after this
or you have family members who are
really just like you know you're not
sticking them anymore
and i actually have a true story about
that whenever i first started out in
nursing
had this sweet patient she was about in
her 90s
and here i am new to nursing and at that
time i wasn't that great at ivs but i
was trying
and i go into the patient's room need to
start an iv and her son who is a little
bit older
comes up to me he didn't even say hi or
anything he was like
you get one stick i was like okay
and i was thinking okay i hope i really
get this and
so i go to start it and he's like you
know they're at the bedside like
watching me
like a hawk making sure i'm doing
everything right and guess what
i miss and um i felt about this big
and just wanted to die really but
anyways
i had to go get another nurse who was
seasoned and she came in
and tried and unfortunately she missed
the first time but she was able to talk
the sun
into allowing her to try again and she
got it on her second attempt
so you really have to watch that and you
have to try to maintain your confidence
whenever
you know things are making you feel like
oh no i don't know if i can get this
another strategy you can do if you do
miss that vein on that first try
is you really want to investigate those
arms very carefully
because the next vein you choose you
want it to be something that you know is
going to work
because unfortunately sometimes you may
not be able to find anything
in the anacubital fossa in the forearm
or
on the dorsum of the hand and you may
have to go
through some non-traditional routes but
sometimes whenever you have to do that
you have to get the doctor's
permission in order to do that and i
have seen that done
like for instance i've seen ivs up here
in the chest i've also seen them on the
dorsum of the foot
one time i had a patient who was a very
heavy drug user
and they had absolutely nothing in their
arms so we had to go
on the top of the foot and another thing
you know if you are
missing veins a lot you need to step
back and ask yourself okay why am i
missing these veins what is going
wrong and some things that can go wrong
is that
you're just not finding a vein to use
that is actually able to hold that gauge
you're using so maybe
the gauge of iv cannula you're using is
way too big for the vein you selected
also you want to get familiar with
anatomy of the arms and where
those large veins veins set and be able
to know how to feel for them what they
feel like they have this
springy squishy feel to them another
thing is that
are you hitting the veins so you're
getting the blood in the chamber
but whenever you go to thread it in
you're having difficulty it's causing
the vein to blow well that could be
because you're not going
in far enough with that needle in order
to slide that cannula off into the vein
that's a big common problem that some
people have
also you may be putting too much
pressure on that vein with the
tourniquet
maybe you shouldn't even use a
tourniquet or if you do use one put it
on there very
lightly just to create pressure because
it's like the same concept with the
balloon
if you have that vein bulging out way
too much and you take that sharp needle
and hit it
all that pressure on that vein is just
going to cause it to blow but let's say
the problem
that you're having for why you're
missing the veins is because you can't
actually
find the vein and get it up there so you
can stick it with a needle
well here are some things that i suggest
that you can do to help you with that
one thing is just to get familiar with
how to palpate a vein
practice filling it and the best person
you can use is really yourself get a
tourniquet put it on your arm
and just feel on your arm where these
veins are located and
how they feel next is to use gravity
gravity is your friend because it's
going to help
cause that blood to pull in those veins
help them pop up so you can find them so
use gravity
have the hand dangled down or the arm
dangle down at the side
and apply a tourniquet as needed and you
can also have the patient
pump their hand but let's say you're
going to be collecting lab values
out of this iv you want to avoid doing
this because it could throw off some of
the lab values that you're collecting
and then another thing you can do is if
you have access to a vein finder or a
vein light these are really cool tools
that
are non-invasive you can put them on the
skin and it'll help
light up where that vein is located or
you can get ultrasound to help
you out with this it really varies on
what you have access to
in your hospital but i have had
ultrasound for patients who are really
hard to stick
they will come and they will actually
ultrasound the vein and they will
actually stick the vein and get the iv
and really another simple thing you can
do is you can use
heat if you have a blanket warmer on
your unit you can get some
warm blankets put those on the arm
especially if your patient's cold
and you can even notice this on yourself
whenever you're cold your veins will
shrink down
or you can get one of those warm
compresses and put those on the veins
just to help expand those out
and it may be that your patient just
literally has nothing to choose from so
they may be a candidate for a central
line but you would want to check with
the physician on that
and lastly you know if you find yourself
being in that situation where you're
just missing veins
all the time and you're never getting
them don't think that this is just a
skill that you're never going to get
because this skill takes lots of
practice unless you're one of those
people who came out of nursing school
just being like naturally awesome at
starting ivs most people it takes lots
of practice
and for me when i write a new nurse this
took practice
and i know it can be difficult whenever
you are missing all the time and maybe a
patient
has said something to you which squishes
your confidence even more
maybe a co-worker is giving you a hard
time about it but whatever it is
just push that out of your mind and just
say okay i'm going to keep practicing
i'm not going to give up because one of
the worst things you can do
is just quit trying and just keep asking
people to start your ivs for you
because there's going to be times when
this patient needs this iv
now because the iv blue you have some
fluids or antibiotics to run you need
the iv and you go out to look for
someone to help you and it's like a
ghost town you can't find anyone
and it comes down to you and this is
really a skill set that you have to have
so what you want to do is you just want
to practice take every opportunity you
can to practice and i know whenever
you are first starting out the skill
seems so complicated
because you have to first find the vein
then you have to stick the vein
and then you have to like have limited
amount of hands to be able to connect to
the extension set to flush it to
occlude it to secure it down and it
seems so
just difficult but over time when you do
this over and over you're gonna get it
and before you know it people may be
coming to you to get you to start their
iv so don't give up
okay so that wraps up this video and if
you'd like to watch more videos like
this you can access the link in the
youtube description below